welcome back well preparations are
underway at the white house next
thursday president biden will hold his
first
formal news conference since taking
office most recent past presidents
including president donald trump
already had a news conference by this
point in their presidencies
so why did it take biden so long and
will he take any tough questions
when he finally faces reporters joining
me right now is kaylee macaneny she is
former trump a white house press
secretary
and a fox news analyst kaylee it's great
to see you tonight
thanks so much for joining us your
reaction to the administration
announcing this press conference more
than a week away
it's an extraordinary decision a
absolutely puzzling one uh dana perino
one of my predecessors
has commented on this network that you
know you don't announce press conference
till the morning i had the same role in
my press office
you don't know what the news cycle is
nine days in advance we know that
there's a crisis
on the southern border that they refuse
to acknowledge no one knows
what that will look like in nine days
but i imagine it will be worse
so she announces this uh gensake the
press secretary in advance presumably to
get the media off her heels but in doing
so really creates
a lot of pressure on president biden
that no matter the news cycle
he will be at that podium well let's not
forget there is a media blackout
over the border right now kaylee and i
know that you were there every day
at that podium answering questions
whatever those questions were lobbed at
you
we are hearing that there is in fact an
unofficial gag order
the by the administration has told the
patrol agents at the border
to not share any information about
what's going on in the migrant crisis
with reporters yes and now we know
exactly why that gag order exists there
was a democrat
senator today who went down to look at
one of these facilities senator
murphy and came out and said that he was
almost brought to tears
by what he saw with these children so
that's why
the gag order exists because in effect
when a sitting senator gets a look at it
they've got to shut off the media shut
off the access because if america saw
those images
there'd be a lot of pressure on
president biden well it's very
unfortunate to see what took place with
with president biden
tripping on his way into air force one
the plane we have this video here
uh of course it it nobody wants to see
this
from the commander-in-chief obviously uh
he
got to to the top and and and saluted
and
at joint base andrews but it's one day
after
another gaffe when he was at the podium
and he actually referred to the vice
president
as the president let's roll that tape
watch
now when president harris and i took a
virtual tour of a vaccination center in
arizona
president harris your reaction
you've got to wonder because it's
becoming a pattern he said something to
the effect on the campaign trail like
the harris biden ticket or his staff had
insignia on one of his campaign stops
uh with that on there so you've gotta
wonder whether there's more to this than
just the slip of the tongue and with
regard to the stairs i
will echo you and say that's very
unfortunate i remember following the
president
off of marine one and i would board
those same stairs after him and you
always got a little nervous about
slipping with the media watching so it
certainly can happen to
just about anyone it certainly can but
the media reacted
when the president had the smallest of
missteps let's roll that video
here's the media who covered president
trump
images like this and even his speaking
uh ability or lack thereof
during this again undercuts
their argument that biden is a
daughtering old man
i've become slightly obsessed with
watching president trump
watch his step the president himself is
having
momentary stumbles uh momentary
lapses and you know it looks restraining
for a word
kaylie i haven't seen any media talk
about
president biden referring to vice
president harris as the president
so far have you no i haven't either
and when president trump slipped on what
was a slippery ramp
my deputy press secretary judd dear
reminded me today it was days-long news
cycle
literally cnn their morning hosts
brought on their chief medical expert to
talk about whether it was indicative of
something neurological
their midday host brought on chris eliza
to talk about his unsteady walk and
lifting of the hand i mean
that is what president trump got and
today at least as of a few
hours ago there was just one mention of
this on cnn i think the
speculation about president trump was
totally wrong and i think doing the same
about biden
is totally not the way to go but cnn it
just they couldn't hide their animosity
for the president along with other media
outlets
yeah no they could not kaylee it's good
to see you tonight thanks so much
good to see you kaylee mcaney joining us
up next